these five Ukrainian families have
traveled long distances to meet their
loved ones in a prison in
russian-controlled Donetsk Arena wants
to see her husband
I spent two days getting here my husband
has been a prisoner since March 2022 and
we have a little daughter all the news I
got about him came through letters that
we exchanged from time to time
emotions are running High the prisoners
were unaware this meeting was going to
happen since the first weeks of the war
more than 2 000 prisoners from both
sides have been exchanged all the
families hope the Rival sides will
become more sympathetic to the plight of
those who are suffering this meeting
lasted only a few moments but the
families here say they're priceless
more than 30 prisoner exchanges have
been held since the outbreak of the war
the United Nations accuses both sides of
committing violations against those they
hold
and international leaders and
organizations have urge both to respect
the Geneva Convention on prisoners of
War
we are ready to organize these visits
which are not the first of their kind
Russia respects all International
agreements related to prisoners of war
the Ukrainian side prevents the families
of prisoners to visit them and their
faith is only known through exchange
lists
the number of prisoners on both sides
has increased as the fighting has
intensified observers say outside Powers
need to put more effort into ensuring
civilians and grain exports are
protected and missing people are
accounted for
and to persuade the warring sides to
open dialogue